[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
der buckingham palast an diesem abend an
den für einen moment die zeit
stillzustehen stand ein ganzes zeitalter
ist zu ende gegangen nicht nur für das
vereinigte königreich
guten abend es gibt diese ereignisse von
denen man weiß dass sie geschehen werden
und das auch in absehbarer zeit aber man
fürchtet sich so sehr davor dass man es
verdrängt so ging es vielen menschen im
vereinigten königreich
sie wussten natürlich dass selbst eine
königin elizabeth nicht unsterblich ist
dass der tag kommen wird bald und dann
ist es trotzdem ein schock mit den
96-jährigen leben der queen endet nicht
nur ein zeitalter sie war für die briten
ja mehr als ein repräsentatives
staatsoberhaupt sie verkörperte die
einheit der nation
elisabeth selbst hatte einmal ihre krone
als lebendiges band bezeichnet das band
das alles zusammenhielt verena geld
berichtet
die flagge auf halbmast sie kommen zum
buckingham palast die briten haben ihre
königin verloren sie haben das erwartet
und sie haben es befürchtet aber alle
ich war im büro als ich gehört habe dass
sie tot ist und ich wollte ich hier her
kommen anstatt nach hause zu gehen wir
meinen respekt zollen nach so vielen
jahren regentschaft das ist das doch
ziemlich plötzlich
ein ganz wichtiger moment ganz egal ob
man sie gut fand oder nicht aber man
kommt einfach nicht drum rum
anzuerkennen dass sie so lange regiert
hat sehr traurig
die letzten öffentlichen bilder
aufgenommen am dienstag im schottischen
balmoral zur ernennung der neuen
premierministerin die queen wirkt
zerbrechlich heute mittag ein
offizielles statement vom palast dass
ein ganzes land in sorge versetzt
die gefühle der briten für ihre königin
sind unheimlich stark was kaum einer hat
in seinem leben eine andere monarchen
gekannt und sie hat ihre rolle mit so
viel entschlossenheit
und anmut ausgefüllt
immer häufiger ließ sie sich im
vergangenen jahr durch ihren sohn prinz
charles vertreten diese ersetze sie
erstmals auch bei der
parlamentseröffnung im mai
über den feierlichkeiten zu ihrem 70
thronjubiläum im juni lag schon ein
moment von abschied sie nahm nur noch
vereinzelt unternehmen teil
sie stand für stabilität und kontinuität
und ich denke jetzt da sie nicht mehr da
ist werden wir uns als nation
hinterfragen müssen und uns stehen
möglicherweise unruhige zeiten bevor
[Musik]
in den letzten stunden waren ihre vier
kinder bei ihr mit ihrem tod ist ihr
ältester sohn er nachfolger prinz
charles ist seit heute könig charles der
dritte
und dann schalten wir zu unserem
korrespondenten andreas stamm in london
andreas das wird sehr spezielle
atmosphäre jetzt seien an diesem abend
in london
buckingham palast eine art aufgeladene
stille trauern trösten ja dass es mit
sicherheit und sind zehntausende die
jetzt dorthin strömen um ihrer königin
die letzte ehre zu erweisen um abschied
zu nehmen und es gibt ganz verrückte
momente wo dann die gibt die masse die
königin dreimal hochleben lässt es ist
eben in den nächsten tagen wird es
unglaublich viele formalien geben
tradition es werden große staatsmänner
und starts frauen große reden halten
aber das ist glaube ich jetzt der moment
vor allen dingen für die londoner die
hier sind um sich zu verabschieden und
es ist ein wenig gänsehaut
im content zu dass die queen sie war
eine der wenigen menschen weltweit der
exakt wusste und ja auch teils selbst
festlegt wie es denn dann unmittelbar
nach ihrem tod weitergeht
ja diese diese vorbereitung auf ihren
tod das ist welcher die sind dicker wie
mancher brockhaus und da gibt es jetzt
einen ganz klaren plan das sind im
endeffekt zwei gleise davon zwei züge
der erste zug das ist der weg der queen
die jetzt aufgebaut ist im ballsaal auf
schloss bürgeln dort wird die familie
abschied nehmen dann wird es in drei
tagen weitergehen nach bebra in die
hauptstadt schottlands dort wird sie
aufgebaut in der essentials kathedrale
dort wird es ein gottesdienst geben die
schotten nehmen abschied und dann tags
darauf geht es nach london und dann
wieder einen tag später dort aufgebahrt
werden das kondolenzbuch ausgelegt und
dann werden sich die londoner
verabschieden können bis eben zum tag 10
das ist dann der tag des der der
beisetzung und ein großer gottesdienst
noch mal in der westminster abbey und
dann geht es eben in die st george's
chapel auf schloss windsor in die
familiengruft neben ihren ehemann prinz
philip ja und der zweite zug der fährt
das ist der des neuen königs charles des
dritten das ist er sozusagen sofort
geworden nachdem die queen ihren letzten
atemzug getan hat aber er wird morgen
dann hier in london in einer zeremonie
offiziell bestätigt wird durchs land
reisen nordirland wales schottland alles
alle landesteile besuchen und eben dann
auch versuchen die briten ja in diesem
trauernden in diesem traurigen moment zu
trösten und ja in einer art einheit zu
bewegen es wird schwierig denn man muss
sagen die fußstapfen die die queen
hinterlässt die wird es könig charles
der dritte schwer haben zu füllen das
ist keine frage der tat dankeschön
andreas nach london schon als junge
thronfolgerin mit gerade mal 21 jahren
sagte elisabeth bei einer radioansprache
ich erkläre vor euch allen dass mein
ganzes leben ob es lang währt oder kurz
den dienst an euch und der großen
familie des empire squibb mit sein soll
das große empire gibt es nicht mehr aber
gedient hat sie so lange wie keine ihrer
vorgänger auf diesem thron ein
lebensbild von diana zimmermann
ein leben im dienste ihres volkes das
hatte elisabeth die zweite sich
vorgenommen länger als jeder andere
monarch großbritanniens regierte sie und
mit jedem jahr wuchsen respekt und
zuneigung für die queen
ich diene ich erkläre vor ihnen allen
dass mein ganzes leben mag es lang oder
kurz sein in ihrem dienst stehen wird
am 2 juni 1953 wird elisabeth die zweite
zur königin von großbritannien und
nordirland gekrönt zum ersten mal wird
die zeremonie im fernsehen live
übertragen der beginn einer regentschaft
von mehr als 60 jahren
von klein auf wird elisabeth auf diese
aufgabe vorbereitet die junge prinzessin
mit schwester margaret und eltern sie
sollte eine möglichst unbeschwerte
jugend haben aber auch früh ihre
pflichten für das land erfüllen
elisabeth als kfz mechanikerin im
zweiten weltkrieg
den den mann ihres lebens prinz philip
verliebt sich elisabeth schon mit 13 8
jahre später heiraten sie in westminster
abbey
mit der geburt des thronfolgers prinz
charles ist das glück des jungen paares
vollkommen
doch 1952 hat das unbeschwerte familien
leben ein ende auf einer weltreise
erfährt elisabeth vom plötzlichen tod
ihres vaters über nacht wird sie königin
muss lernen pflichten und verantwortung
einer monarchen zu tragen
dazu gehört die jährliche eröffnung des
parlaments und das verlesen des
regierungsprogramms was sie davon hielt
blieb ihr geheimnis so wie auch niemand
erfuhr was sie von ihren insgesamt 14
premierminister dachte
1992 feuer auf schloss windsor noch dazu
gehen in diesem jahr die ehen zweier
ihrer kinder in die brüche das
schreckensjahr nathusius
noch tiefer die krise als fünf jahre
später der jänner stirbt die prinzessin
des volkes er ist unter dem druck der
öffentlichkeit findet königin in dieser
bett worte der trauer und damit wieder
den anschluss an die stimmung im land
eine königin die sich stets mühte das
land zu einen in den schweren stunden
nach den terroranschlägen im juli 2005
geht sie sofort zu den vernetzten
2017 nach dem brand des grenzfall
hochhauses trifft sie betroffene und
2020 im schweren ko widerspricht sie den
briten mut zu
disziplin ruhige gut gelaunter
entschiedenheit und mitgefühl
charakterisieren dieses land nach wie
vor sehr stolz auf das was wir sind
liegt nicht in der vergangenheit er
definiert unsere gegenwart und unsere
zukunft des vereins abwesend
immer wieder kommt sie nach deutschland
das letzte mal 2015 eine emotionale
reise große zuneigung schlägt der queen
entgegen die vor der erinnerung an den
krieg nicht zurückscheut zum ersten mal
besuchen sie und philipp ein
konzentrationslager das von den briten
befreite bergen welt
ihre wohl schwierigste außenpolitische
mission erfüllt sie im mai 2011
staatsbesuch in irland der erste eines
britischen monarchen seit 100 jahren
elisabeth kommt und hilft bei der
versöhnung zweier völker mit schwieriger
gemeinsam markt geschichte
[Applaus]
weniger gut gelingt es ihr zwist in der
eigenen familie zu schlichten die
hoffnung der monarchie durch die heirat
prinz harrys mit der us amerikanischen
schauspielerin megan marke einen
modernen multikulturellen schub zu geben
zerschlägt sich rasch als die beiden
sich von der königlichen familie
lossagen
vereins sieht man die familie erst
wieder zu einem traurigen anlass der
beerdigung von prinz philip im april
70 jahre lang war er der gefeierte der
königin
[Musik]
juni 2022 der letzte große auftritt
anlässlich ihres im ganzen königreich
gefeierten siebzigsten thronjubiläums
gemeinsam mit drei thronfolger zeigt
sich die alte dame auf dem balkon ihres
palastes charles william und tod werden
es schwer haben die großen fußstapfen
ihrer vorgängerin auszufüllen
und dann schalten wir ins englische
städtchen stadt darf mit einem briten
darüber zu sprechen was dieser tag
bedeutet james ist schriftsteller und
germanist hat die kürzeste geschichte
deutschlands geschrieben und auch das
buch die kürzeste geschichte england
guten abend müsste holz
das ist ja ein schwieriger zeitpunkt zu
dem die königin stirbt denn das
vereinigte königreich wird zumindest uns
auf uns nicht wirklich vor allem nicht
das ist ja genau das problem dann die
königin hat seit jahren ein sehr tiefes
psychologisches bedürfnis in uns gefühlt
mehr als 1 soll dazu führen dass in
jedem menschen natürlich aber in zeiten
des umbruchs oder gar des verfalls ist
das umso wichtiger und wenn man zum
beispiel war heute einfach die financial
times
schlagzeilen man sieht und merkt dass
der fundstelle noch seinen historischen
tiefstand erreicht hat erkennt man was
für schwerter zeigen uns
erwarten und wie wir diese figur
vermissen werden es ist ja vielleicht
auch fast symbolisch dass sie in
schottland also auf ihren sommersitz in
bayern gestorben ist denn schottland
könnte da könnte es die erste
absetzbewegungen
geben oder unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen
die jetzt neu ausbrechen die wie
schätzen sie das ein die werden jetzt
stärker werden denn die königin genießt
in schotten wie sonstwo in dem
vereinigten königreich ein sehr starkes
persönliches
respekt ja sogar von von oder apotheker
zu läuten aber wenn sie weg ist wird
sich diese zahl wahrscheinlich ja mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht an charles übertragen und die
unabhängigkeitsbewegung in schottland
was die große bedrohung für das
vereinigte königreich darstellt werden
sicher umso stärker werden da sie gerade
vom zauber sprechen also das wird ja
auch im zusammenhang mit der monarchie
auch ist das auch so ein begriff die
magie der monarchie oder der würdevolle
teil des des des staates das wird für
ihren nachfolger führerscheins den
dritten schwierig werden das auch so zu
verkörpern oder geschrieben sieht sie
war sie war mehr als eine wenn wir das
eine königin eigentlich denn wenn man
eine so lange regenten schafft gehört
hat besteht die gefahr für den
thronfolger dass die institution sich
mit der person zu sagen vermischt hat
und wenn die person dass in diesem fall
die königin steht
weiß man wirklich nicht mehr was die was
die institution wohne sie für bedeutung
hat denn während sie hat uns sozusagen
durch allen stadien des umbruchs gar des
verfalls
beiseite gestanden 70 jahre lang sein
und in diesen 70 jahre lang er ist nicht
england ist das fand ich bin gleich
immer wieder schwächer vereinzelt sei
nicht mehr das große reich der dann der
vergangenheit gewesen und das problem
wahrscheinlich ist dass sie einfach
durch ihre anwesenheit durch
standhaftigkeit
es fehlen von uns ermöglicht hat weg von
der wirklichkeit zu sehen und noch leben
zu wollen ebenso können als ob wir noch
das waren was wir einst waren
was sie jetzt gar nichts sind und das
ist nicht immer halb voll für ein land
kann man das sehr leicht formulieren das
kann man wohl so sagen ja zu hause ich
danke ihnen sehr dass ihr heute abend
zeit für uns hatten dankeschön nachbar
königin elizabeth wird nicht nur den
briten fehlen sie war zwar keine
herrscherin und trotzdem war sie ein
diskreter und beständiger teil der
weltpolitik allein wenn man daran denkt
wie viele regierende sie kommen und
gehen sagen nicht nur in ihrem eigenen
land und sie wirken auch tatsächlich auf
der ganzen welt betrauert christian von
rechenberg hat die internationalen
reaktionen dieses abends
zusammengestellt
immer mehr menschen kommen zum
buckingham palace heute abend
großbritannien trauert und mit dem land
die ganze welt die sprecherin des us
präsidenten von der nachricht überrascht
das bestätigt
unsere herzen fährt sie fort und unsere
gedanken sind bei der familie der könige
gleiche worte kommen von indiens
premierminister die queen
personifizierte in unser aller leben
würde und anstand der amtskollege aus
israel schreibt ihr vermächtnis ist
einzigartig friedrich merz erinnert an
die queen als symbol für verlässlichkeit
und würde this truck großbritanniens
neue premierminister man kaum im amt
muss das land rüsten
die nachricht aus berlin model hat uns
alle am boden zerstört der tod ihrer
majestät der königin ist ein gewaltiger
schock für das land und für die welt
königin elizabeth die zweite rheinfels
auf den das moderne großbritannien
erbaut wurde
justin krueger kondoliert im namen
kanadas die queen war eine konstante in
unserem leben und was sie für unser land
getan hat bleibt unvergessen der
bundeskanzler erinnert an eine
versöhnung nach dem krieg sie wird
fehlen nicht zuletzt ihr wundervoller
humor eine freundin frankreichs nennt
emanuele makro die verstorbene einer
gutmütige königin die ihr land und ihr
jahrhundert geprägt hat euro ich hoffe
dass das britische volk und die
königliche familie in dieser zeit der
trauer trost finden und stolz empfinden
können für den enormen beitrag den ihre
majestät zur förderung und stärkung der
britisch-irischen beziehungen geleistet
hat
tröstende worte aus der ukraine
die eigentlich selbst trost braucht und
von den vereinten nationen sie war eine
freundin schreibt der generalsekretär
und eine beruhigende konstante in zeiten
des wandels und
amerikas präsident ergänzt seine
sprecherin er ehrt die tote als
staatsfrau von unvergleichlicher würde
und beständigkeit
juni 2015 war königin dieser welt das
letzte mal zu besuch in deutschland theo
koll wie wird sie in berlin offiziell
betrauert die gesamte staats und
politische spitze hat sehr schnell und
sehr intensiv in berlin reagiert und
beides darf man glaube ich wirklich als
ausdruck der ungeheuren wertschätzung
sind der bundespräsident hat die
verstorbene monarchie neben
ausführlichen schloss bellevue gewürdigt
mit tiefer trauer habe ich die nachricht
vom tod ihrer majestät königin
elizabeth der zweite
vernommen
königin elizabeth war eine frau die ein
jahrhundert geprägt hat im vereinigten
königreich
und darüber hinaus weltweit sie hat zeit
geschichte erlebt und
zeitgeschichte geschrieben ihre majestät
genoss auf der ganzen welt
höchstes ansehen und respekt
bei uns hier in deutschland wurde sie
bewundert und verehrt millionen deutsche
fühlen sich heute in trauer und
herzliche anteilnahme
mit den menschen im vereinigten
königreich
verbunden
ihre
natürliche autorität
ihre immense erfahrung ihre vorbildliche
pflichterfüllung werden uns in
lebendiger erinnerung bleiben
ihr tod ist ein tiefer einschnitt
das ende einer epoche
der kanzler hat heute abend ebenso wie
viele spitzenpolitiker insbesondere ihre
verdienste um die deutsch britische
versöhnung nach dem schrecken des
zweiten weltkriegs hervorgehoben die
queen habe so sagen sie deutschland die
hand zur versöhnung gereicht die sei ein
symbol für verlässlichkeit und würde
eine moralische instanz gewiesen
deutschland das wird heute abend aus
allen äußerungen klar verliert eine
königliche freundin
dankeschön thema nach berlin
und dann wird wenn wir uns den neuen
britischen könig schon im vierzehnten
jahrhundert wählte der damalige fürst
von wales für sich das motto ich ging
wobei der ursprung dieser zwei deutsch
klingenden worte wohl eher flämisch oder
walisisch ist letzteres hieße übersetzt
dann so viel wie man jedenfalls steht
dieses motto ich den heute noch auf dem
wappen des prince of wales des
thronfolgers nun ist der bisherige prinz
könig charts der dritte ein könig der
fast 74 jahre im wartestand war um nun
das amt anzutreten das von geburt an für
ihn vorgesehen war charles wird das
bereits als eine lange zeit des dienens
erlebt haben aber nicht jeder im
königreich ist überzeugt dass er auch
ihr mann ist im sinne von der richtige
film tron ein porträt von andreas stamm
ein vor bestimmtes leben vom ersten
moment an der thronfolger im
anbrechenden tv zeitalter seit frühster
kindheit stolz präsentiert sein
werdegang
standesgemäß nur das beste ob internat
universität oder offiziersausbildung bei
der räume wie segen und fluch des
erstgeborenen
als charles ein teenager war gab die
queen ein abendessen mit dem
premierminister dem erzbischof von
canterbury den befehlshaber der
streitkräfte um zu entscheiden was
machen wir als nächstes mit schals
welche universität was dann nur eine
person fehlte dabei prinz charles ihm
wurde mitgeteilt das sind die dinge die
du nun tun wirst
seine mutter wird königin da ist er
nicht mal vier der vater schwört auf das
erziehungs prinzip abhärtung die zutaten
für eine eher unglückliche kindheit
[Musik]
ist ein künstlerisch veranlagte typ sehr
viel sensibler als sein vater der sehr
streng war ihn nicht wirklich verstand
und schals gegenüber ein harter hund war
verglichen dazu war seine mutter
liebevoll aber sie war so gut wie nieder
seine kindheit war geprägt davon dass er
eher vernachlässigt wurde
ein treueschwur zu füßen seiner mutter
so wird er offiziell zum thronfolger
charles
prinz von wales bin euer lebens man mit
leib und leben
er wird zum längsten könig im wartestand
aller zeiten
ich habe mir das alles im lauf der jahre
selbst ausgedacht wie man ja sieht
wahrscheinlich ist es letztlich gut dass
die rolle des prinzen von wales nicht
definiert es dass sich
die von ihm gegründete stiftungen wird
zur größten
wohltätigkeitsorganisation des landes
ist ein langjähriges engagement für den
umweltschutz wird zuerst belächelt nun
gilt er als einer der ersten prominenten
banner vor einer klimakrise
wird sehr wahrscheinlich ein großer
umwelt könig sein ein grüner monarch der
richtige mann zur richtigen zeit und am
richtigen ort gerade jetzt wo der
umweltschutz weltweit so viele sorgen
bereitet
die tragik seines lebens die ehe mit
ryan es beginnt mit einer
märchenhochzeit es folgte eine beziehung
die zumindest anfangs glücklich scheint
zwei prinzen william und harry die
thronfolge gesichert es endet in einem
rosenkrieg einer öffentlichen
schlammschlacht
dazu das tragische ende der yen als bei
einem auto unfall kurz nach der
scheidung es stürzt die monarchie in die
krise schickt charles beliebtheitswerte
in den keller bis heute sehen viele
briten in ihm den bericht
[Musik]
ebene fällt selbst wenn sie in diesem
krieg zwischen prinz und prinzessin in
den neunzigern nicht auf seiner seite
waren kein kritiker hat ihn in seiner
rolle als vater angegriffen ich denke er
war ein sehr guter vater man bedenke nur
wie seine jungs die so schwierigen jahre
durchgestanden haben
das private glück hat charles mit der
heirat seiner jugendliebe camilla
gefunden
spätestens seit dem tod von prinz philip
ist er das unumschränkte
familienoberhaupt er konnte lange in
diese rolle hineinwachsen genau wie ihm
die des königs die bestimmung seines
lebens seit mehr als 70 jahren und
[Musik]
zum tod von königin elisabeth nun einen
kommentar vom chefredakteur des zdf
peter frey
mit queen elizabeth der zweite verliert
die welt eine jahrhundertfigur eine frau
die in großbritannien eine ganze epoche
repräsentierte wie ihre ahnen queen
elizabeth die erste und queen victoria
auch für deutschland war sie mehr als
das staatsoberhaupt eines befreundeten
landes schon als junge königin hatte sie
die bundesrepublik verzaubert und dieser
zauber sich auch in 70 jahren
regentschaft nicht auch als sich das
royale familien drama entfaltete und aus
den windsors fast eine seifenoper machte
die queen verkörperte würde als royale
ehen zerbrachen dajana starb oder ein
feuer schloss windsor verwüstete mit den
wenigen worten die sie offiziell
sprechen konnte mit der kraft ihrer
persönlichkeit mit stiff upper lip heci
großbritannien und ihre komplizierte
familie zusammen beeindruckte die welt
never complain never explain niemals
klagen niemals erklären so war sie im
dienst ist ganz zum schluss als
oberhaupt des commonwealth stand
elisabeth für ein empire das längst
untergegangen war jetzt endet ihr
zeitalter ihr tod trifft ein politisch
sozial und regional tief gespaltenes
königreich ins mark in den 90er jahren
noch ein teil von cool britannia stand
die queen zuletzt einer gesellschaft vor
die sich durch die eigenheiten ihrer
elite durch undurchlässigkeit und ein
übersteigertes nationales
selbstbewusstsein in europa isoliert
deutschland verneigt sich heute vor dem
leben der britischen königin die die
allermeisten von uns so lange begleitet
hat in der sprache der symbolik
präsentierte sich elisabeth vor dem
brett sit in blau und gelb baute so doch
noch eine brücke zwischen london und dem
kontinent ihr tod ist ein verlust und
ein einschnitt auch für uns
königin elizabeth hat in ihrem leben in
ihrem langen leben viele schwere krisen
erlebt aber auch dass noch schlimmen
zeiten wieder bessere kommen können im
moment sind wir ja in eher dunklen
zeiten und der krieg den russland
angezettelt hat trifft den europäischen
kontinent zu einem zeitpunkt an dem er
schon geschwächt waren pandemie krieg
energiekrise inflation da kommt einiges
zusammen gegen das sich gesellschaft
wirtschaft und politik stemmen müssen
und heute ging die europäische
zentralbank in den kampfmodus sozusagen
mit diesen anderen themen geht es jetzt
bei heinz wolf weiter die europäische
zentralbank hat den leitzins auf 1,25
angehoben das ist eine erhöhung um 0,75
prozentpunkte und die größte in der
geschichte der gemeinsamen euro-währung
von bethmann was hat das für folgen für
die verbraucher naja unmittelbar zu
niedrigeren preisen führt das jetzt
nicht auch wenn viele das hoffen werden
die energiepreise beispielsweise werden
weiter hoch bleiben denn die ursache
dafür der krieg in der ukraine ist
nichts was die ezb mit zinsen
beeinflussen könnte sehr wohl einfluss
wird dieser sehr große zinsschritt
dagegen auf die kreditkosten haben
konsumenten oder baukredite werden
teurer der kreditvermittler interhyp
rechnet damit dass die hypothekenzinsen
für zehnjährige darlehen bis zum
jahresende auf etwa 3,5 prozent steigen
werden und ja auch auf spareinlagen wird
es wieder zinsen geben minizinsen
vielleicht die durch die immense
teuerung aber mehr als weggefressen
werden um die hohe inflation einzufangen
hat die ezb bereits heute durchblicken
lassen dass weitere zinsschritte folgen
werden viele der händler hier rechnen
damit dass der leitzins zum jahresende
bei 2,5 prozent stehen wird
vielen dank
im bundestag gegen heute die
haushaltswoche weiter der etat von
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck wurde
beraten habe kündigte dabei angesichts
der gestiegenen energiekosten
unterstützung an die gerade auch kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen helfen sollen
das programm werde zeitlich befristet
sein weil man an anderen instrumenten
arbeiten um den preisanstieg zu stoppen
und so bürger und unternehmen zu
entlasten
der bundestag hat nach einer
kontroversen debatte heute auch eine
reihe von neuregelungen zum corona
schutz in diesem herbst und winter
beschlossen zu den zentralen punkten
zählen masken pflichten in
krankenhäusern in pflegeheimen und den
arztpraxen ebenfalls im fernverkehr aber
nicht mehr in flugzeugen die
bundesländer können weitere auflagen
vorschreiben
us-außenminister blinken war heute
unerwartet zu einem besuch in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew er kündigte
dabei langfristige militärhilfen von
mehr als zwei milliarden dollar an und
us-verteidigungsminister osten sagte bei
einer internationalen konferenz auf dem
militär stützpunkt in ramstein ein neues
waffenpaket für die ukraine zu im umfang
von
675 millionen euro deutschland ist zudem
bereit ukrainische soldaten bei der
räumung von landminen und dem beseitigen
von sprengfallen auszubilden
seit 2009 10 beraten deutsche katholiken
im reformprozess synodaler weg über
neuerungen heute trat in frankfurt am
main zum vierten mal die synodalen
versammlung aus bischöfen priestern
kirchlichen mitarbeitern und zahlreichen
leyen vertretern zu sammeln bereits
heute wurde über ein grundsatzpapier für
eine liberalisierung der katholischen
sexuallehre abgestimmt es erhielt bei
den bischöfen keine zweidrittelmehrheit
und scheiterte noch bis samstag soll
über eine reihe weiterer papiere beraten
werden
und damit sind wir am ende unserer
sendung an diesem tag der in die
geschichtsbücher eingeht für die briten
geht das einher mit einem ungewissen
blick in die zukunft
doch nicht nur das vereinigte königreich
verabschiedet sich von einer königin die
immer da zu sein schien und geradezu
ewiglich wirkte
gibt es dann noch eine ausführliche
dokumentation über elisabeth die zweite
mit dem titel die queen ein leben für
die gruppe
[Musik]
erinnerungen an in dieser bett die
zweite nach dem dokumentation über ihr
leben meldet sich dann maybrit illner
mit ihren gästen und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wenn ihr wiedersehen
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen der sommer
in europa war mit abstand der rekord
heißeste wir sehen diese blauen flächen
nur hier rund um island oder in der
ägäis ansonsten war es fast überall viel
zu warm wir sehen das an der roten farbe
der grund dafür ist die klimakrise mit
ihren stabilen wetterlage die auch diese
drei großen hitzewellen in europa in
diesem sommer möglich gemacht hat und
auch wir liegen hier aktuell in einer
sehr stabilen langlebigen wetterlage
dieses hoch liegt im norden schon über
zwei wochen auch tief peggy liegt schon
über einer woche über dem atlantik bevor
es uns dann jetzt erreicht hat und auch
mal endlich diesen verbreiteten
langlebigen regen gebracht hat dahinter
folgt jetzt etwas kühle luft und damit
im südwesten heute nacht schon einzelne
schauer und gewitter sonst ist es
aufgelockert bewölkt aber in
schleswig-holstein
mecklenburg-vorpommern brandenburg und
berlin schüttet ist noch richtig heftig
in der ersten nachthälfte danach zieht
das ganze dann richtung nordosten ab die
temperaturen sinken in der nacht auf 14
bis 8 grad am alpenrand morgen liegen
die temperaturen zwischen 17 und 24 grad
dazu ist es vormittags wechselnd bewölkt
erste schauer haben wir schon in der
westhälfte das wird dann am nachmittag
aber deutlich mehr dann wechseln sich
kurze schauer und gewitter ab mit
trockenen vielleicht auch sonnige phasen
also ist es richtig aprilwetter im
september aber der wind der ist spürbar
herbstlich aus südwestlichen richtungen
am samstag bleibt es unbeständig an
sonnen sonntag haben wir noch reste im
südosten und am montag wird dann schon
wieder trockener und kurzzeitig wärmer
[Musik]
ein langes leben dass viele
unvergessliche bilder geschaffen hat
wie werden wir sie erinnern
als cooles bond girl
als ewig lächelnde kronen trägerin
als die kleine alte dame mit hut
als automechanikerin im krieg
als ur großmutter oder als gastgeberin
für helden und diktatoren
als die die schon immer da war und nun
eine lücke hinterlässt und einen
thronfolger für ein land das sie die
letzten jahrzehnte zusammen hielt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das erste kind von prinz albert und
seiner schottischen ehefrau elisabeth
per kaiserschnitt kam elisabeth junior
auf die welt und obwohl es 1926 sehr
unwahrscheinlich schien dass sie einmal
königin werden würde verfolgten die
briten ihr heranwachsen mit großem
interesse
die prinzessin und ihre vier jahre
jüngere schwester margaret hatten bis
1936 eine heitere kindheit so heißt es
und so saß aus bequem der vater der
queen york der sechste beschrieb seine
familie immer als bier vier eine sehr
geschlossene familieneinheit sie hatten
ein wirklich idyllisch